we are focusing on the health of our
family and so and so we will be we will
be stronger when we come out of this
because that's what we're determined to
do as a family
Angelina Jolie opening up about her
split from Brad Pitt on Tuesdays Good
Morning America in the past he described
Brad often as a wonderful father of
course is part of the family do you
still believe that of course of course
well we will always be a family
boys the 41 year old actress did the
interview from Cambodia she's promoting
her film first they killed my father
about a Cambodian refugee the heart of
it is long story it's the story of a war
through the eyes of a child but it is
also the story of a country Angelina who
adopted her now 15 year old son Maddox
from the country in 2002 talked about
his involvement in the project I wanted
to understand him and his culture in a
deeper way and I wanted to to bring this
story to this country in their language
Angelina's interview comes just weeks
after she and Brad released a joint
statement stating they both signed
agreements to keep all future court
documents privates
[Music]